hey guys my name is Dave Ramsey welcome
to a message of hope I do a talk radio
show called the Dave Ramsey show for
those of you that are new to us I've
been doing it for almost thirty years
taking calls from people asking me
questions about their money in their
life that is evolved into a whole
company called Ramsey solutions where we
talk about all areas of people's lives
and certainly there's a lot going on in
our culture right now with me for this
conversation tonight is Rachael Cruz and
Aborn best-selling author a couple of
times over and a big star on YouTube is
a team member of ours Ramsey solutions
Ramsey personality she's also my
daughter and Ken Coleman is with us
Ramsey personality and they're born
best-selling author of the book
proximity principle and he does the ken
Coleman show on careers and jobs and has
been doing that for quite a while and
radio stations all over America in a
very popular podcast so they're going to
join in with this conversation in this
time of weirdness this time of crisis
this time of fear in America today
people are really scared
some are terrified some are hysterical
some are just concerned and I don't know
which category you fall into tonight and
most of us kind of vacillate among those
categories depending on what we're
talking about whether we're talking
about the medical issue with the
coronavirus or we're talking about the
corona shutdown and the number of jobs
lost and where we are there it's just a
hard time in our culture right now
certainly in the United States and for
that matter around the world so the
first thing we want to tell you is this
I'm old you can tell I've been there and
we're gonna get through this
you're okay it's gonna work out I was
there when y2k was gonna end the world
and it didn't and businesses went crazy
and jobs were a Miss and the economy was
crazy and and I was there after
nine-one-one some of you weren't born
yet
I understand but there was a time there
that we really worried in America and we
grabbed
and we were unified but the stock market
took us on a ride and the economy took
us on a ride I've been through a couple
of flu breakouts of different names and
people were scared nothing like this
particular virus has scared everyone but
I watched a lot of people be sick and
it's it's a sad time in America in that
regard went through 2007-2008 and I did
a hundred and seventy-eight media hits
and about seven days in those days
because it was crazy and I was trying to
tell people to calm down to not cash in
everything and not abandon hope because
if you haven't noticed there is one
thing more contagious than this virus
and it's fear it's airborne and people
you don't need social distancing won't
even help it's coming through your
television screen it's coming through
your news feeds on your computer it's
coming from friends and relatives who
normally we're pretty level-headed
people but are panicked right now or at
least scared or at a minimum concerned
so just hear me loud and clear you're
okay we're gonna get through this twelve
months from today you can write it down
right now
and you can send me hate mail if you
want if I'm wrong but twelve months from
today we're gonna look back on this and
go wow that was rough we got through it
the same thing we said about those other
calamities and crisis's that I just
outlined a couple of principles that
we're gonna get into tonight number one
is my friend art Laffer says no one
makes good decisions when they're
panicked or when they're drunk some of
your both
some of you chosen one over the other
sometimes you are just panicked or just
in a moment in time just in a five
minute period of time you can become
panicked and do something that takes
years to get your family past the
mistake that you make while you're out
of control your critical thinking skills
just dissipate when your panics you've
got to calm down you got to calm down
our friend another mg personality dr.
John Delaney he's a crisis counselor and
he says when you're in a crisis facts
are your friends facts or your friends
and and you have to control your input
what is coming into your brain is a
continual newsfeed of fear are you
watching the news channels 24/7 I got to
tell you there's very few people have a
strong enough spiritual Constitution to
do that and not cave to the fear I don't
do that I'm a part of that media I'm on
all those shows on all those stations
while those people are my friends but I
am NOT going sit and feed my brain that
all day long my friend Zig Ziglar used
to say when he was alive he said every
morning I read the Bible and read the
newspaper that way I can tell what both
sides are doing so the this is real you
guys you have to control your inputs and
you have to have self control over your
emotions when you're panicked some of
you are you're just melting down and you
lose your ability to make good decisions
other times you're getting mean and
you're being nasty to each other or
you're shaming people on your Facebook
page because they didn't do exactly what
you thought they ought to do one way or
the other but people that are normally
nice people when they get in this funk
emotionally are being very unkind some
of you've been unkind to your own family
and you ought to be ashamed of yourself
some of you've been unkind to someone in
the drugstore because they walked across
the dadgum blue line and you lost your
mind
calm down we need a lot of generosity
right now the Bible says I'm a person of
faith if you don't know and the Bible
says in Jeremiah God says I've got a
plan for you and it's not to bring you
harm it's to bring you hope hope is
greater than fear but it's a choice and
no one can take your hope and no one can
steal your hope you have to surrender it
that's what has to happen otherwise
you're not there and Rachel we were
talking about this idea of just having a
little bit of grace in our lives and we
were talking about what we're going to
say tonight yeah I mean our theme
through tonight really is about
controlling the controllables and how
key that is in this
and that includes your emotions and your
grace for people Christie right who's
another one of our rooms of
personalities we're friends we're
talking on the phone just last week when
all this stuff was happening and she
made a great point and she just said man
we just need to like extend massive
amounts of grace to people because you
never know what someone else is dealing
with right cuz I'm like there's the two
extremes of how people are dealing with
it it's either like this is all crazy
I'm gonna do whatever I want or it's the
ones that are all you know they're
freaked out to do anything and each side
looks at each other and they just they
they spew shame and hate and everything
and I'm like man you know no matter
which side you're on look at the other
side because both both need grace and I
think that's really important to
remember that with your friends your
family it is a time just to say you know
what they're handling things differently
than I would but I'm gonna just take a
deep breath myself and extend that you
can when we're talking about you and I
are teaching leadership sometimes and
we're in these different settings you
know when people are under pressure
sometimes it's just financial pressure
we're talking about sometimes it's other
things but when they're under pressure
it's the the bad parts of their
character are revealed sometimes that's
right and sometimes the best parts of
their character revealed yeah and you
need to be real careful to control that
that's something you can control
yeah I think you're speaking to
influence here and not just for leaders
but for all of us and I love the point
Rachel that you made about grace you
know this is a time where in isolation
when you are around just your friends
and family that they're looking to you
to see what your cues are how are you
handling all this uncertainty how are
you handling the bad news you know
Matthew 5:14 Dave and Rachel says you
are the light of the world a city set on
a hill cannot be hidden and I think
that's a strong challenge to all of us
to realize that in that verse we
realized that we have the opportunity in
uncertainty you could say dark times we
have the opportunity to be light as
individuals as leaders and we are all
exposed in this this is not a state
crisis this isn't a United States crisis
this is a global crisis and it is
affecting everyone and each of us has a
responsibility David Rachel to
realize that we are a city set on a hill
in that we are doing life with some
people closer then maybe we've been
doing life with them in a long time due
to this isolation and so it's really
important as we get to this theme
tonight
what can you control and we're gonna
talk through that tonight but really
controlling Dave our response and
there's gonna be times we all get
squeezed and it reveals the ugly side of
us and we all have the ugly side but we
can choose in this moment to say oh I
don't like that I've got to change that
because I am a light and I want to shine
in uncertainty so I think that's a
wonderful challenge for all of us right
now there's so many things going on I
mean we've got a obviously we have a
medical crisis going on and none of us
are medical people so we're not even in
a position to address that but there's a
jobs crisis millions of millions and
millions of people have lost their jobs
right and and with that comes a money
crisis so those two things are two
things that you can respond to your
situation and control the controllables
st. Augustine is quoted as saying pray
like it all depends on God work like it
all depends on you there's a portion of
this up to God and there's a portion
that's up to you so this is a time when
you have the opportunity to plant or a
time when you have the opportunity to
harvest or a time in your particular
situation where you do whichever of
those is fine but but you have to
control the part you can control and
there are some things you can control
and if you do those the hope will come
and replace the fear I've noticed a
microcosm of that over the years of
counseling folks that are hurting with
money and when I was going broke I can
sit down with someone who's got
astronomical overwhelming debt and even
sit down take the call on the radio and
when I walk them through and they see
with their budget that they can control
today and that that gives them a shot at
having a better tomorrow now their debt
didn't change the numbers didn't change
the idea though that they controlled
what they could control they suddenly
their countenance shifts and you see
hope come I think that's a really
important piece cuz right now I feel
like on an ass
you know level we're getting you know
things done from Washington state level
governors are doing a press conference
don't I mean like there are things that
you just you can't control any of that
right but when you say and like for your
money specifically you have a plan in
place and you can say okay I can do this
and what it does it brings power back to
you and not in someone else's hands and
I think that that's key and I think when
we're fearful we lose all of that and
it's almost like we let go of things and
think okay I don't even know what to do
now but when you say no no no here's the
step by step is what we're gonna walk
through tonight but to really say yeah
these are the things that you are able
to do and completely change your destiny
and this is this is a message that we
speak of RAAM solutions other than the
coronavirus or not that you it's your
decision like if you want to change your
life and do something different
it's up to you and this is a perfect
great time to dive into that be not
conformed to this world but be
transformed by the renewing of your
minds and it's entirely possible now
again we're not being positive thinking
gurus and saying you just ignore
everything around you there's real stuff
happening all around you most of that
you can't control you can control what
you can control and my friend art
Williams used to say all you can do is
all you can do and all you can do is
enough and that's all you can do you
just got to do what you can do pretty
sure there's about three categories
based on the millions it feels like of
questions we're getting hammered within
the last two weeks that we wanted to
respond to they're kind of wrapped up in
there's people into about three
different situations and I want to give
you some practical we want to give you
some practical things to do in those
three situations first situation that
you might find yourself in is maybe you
were in a service industry maybe you're
in the hospitality world working for a
restaurant or a hotel or an airline or a
cruise line or a bar and you're just out
of business you're the person that owns
the business that you were working for
just shut down they didn't have the
money to keep paying everybody you lost
your job and you're scared and there's
about six million people have lost their
jobs so far in the corona shutdown
so far as of this broadcast tonight so
jobs report came out that's just this
month and so what we're tracking that's
the numbers that we're seeing in the
real world where we live out here where
people are shut down and they're losing
their jobs if that's you then when
someone's in a crisis and you're in the
middle of a crisis what we want you to
do is stop doing anything with money
except what we call the four walls you
protect the four walls of your home
first thing you do before you do
anything else as you buy food for your
family second thing you do is you keep
the lights and water on the third thing
you do is pay the rent of the mortgage
and keep shelter you get the car current
keep the car current keep gas in the car
food shelter clothing transportation and
utilities if you're old like me we used
to have a thing called civics class in
the seventh grade and they taught us the
basics of life in the necessities of
life the food shelter transportation and
utilities the necessities take care of
those all the other stuff is a Monopoly
game you get behind on your student loan
you get behind on your credit card you
get behind on something else for a month
or two even until you get turned and get
back re-employed or something else is
happening
you can survive but you take care of
your household
well my credit might get damaged it
might well I might have this happen it
might but you take care of your house
take care of your own household first or
you're worse than an unbeliever take
care of the basics if you're in the
middle of a crisis and there's a lot of
peace with that man because you're not
doing other things with money thinking
okay I'm trying to fund my 401k I'm
trying to do X Y you know you're trying
to do all these things and stop giving
it we're giving you permission to stop
that and just to say and once you see
okay we can get ripped we can get the
rent and mortgage paid we have the food
budget we have this X Y & Z okay it's
it's I we can survive this right I mean
it does it gives you this level of peace
because it is it's a thing you can
control and when the money comes in
that's what you do but if you've lost
your job can I know you've you talk
about this all the time but finding work
right now that's another big priority
for these people what's absolutely a
priority because if we look at what
Dave's talking about the fundamentals
what do you have to do
we've shifted from what do you want to
do to what do you have to do and and
that's a reality for folks and once you
have that confidence Dave you talked
about it as beautiful as you recounted
times you set with people and counseled
them and when you've been able to give
them this is what you do today that's
what you said I love that and folks I
hope you heard that because what we're
gonna talk about over the next few
minutes is all about what you can do
controlling the controls but Dave when
you did that for folks and that's what
you do on the air it's what we at Ramsey
solutions do every day is give people a
clear path and when they know what they
can do today and when you know what you
can do today to take care of what
matters most here's what happens clarity
washes over you I'm very clear on what I
can do today and more importantly what I
need to do today and then confidence
begins to take over and that is huge and
that's why what we teach and the clarity
of this moment is so powerful you know
it don't go into that if you're in that
situation and you've lost you know you
lost a job don't go into that you don't
need to do that you need to go get work
and Ken's gonna talk about that or you
know there's a lot of stuff you can do
he's gonna walk you through some of
those things but you may have to tap
into savings but you may not have to if
you just batten down the hatches and say
the hurricane is coming but hurricanes
don't last forever and there's there's
that when the when he goes by the Sun is
gonna come out and we're gonna sing that
song you know and all that stuff right
and so you're gonna be there you're
gonna be there but just take care of
your family there's something emotional
happens but people get crazy even when
we're just coaching them without a
coronavirus when they're just in a
crisis and they stay current on their
stupid MasterCard and their lights get
cut off and it's so illogical but when
we're scared to death we're not logical
we're panicked we're not making good
decisions so we're telling you take care
of your four walls if that's your
situation do those basic things pile of
cash and and if you get a huge
polycation you want to go back to paying
some of the other bills before
everything goes by that's okay that's
okay you can do that the second group of
people other than the ones that are in
the middle of a crisis is the people
that are kind of in the middle
you're doing ok not a problem today but
you're kind of looking over your
shoulder like something's getting ready
to hit you
you know like something's coming I don't
know what's coming and there's really
almost within that category there's
almost two kinds of people there's a
person who's you know they're working
what we call our baby steps are working
a financial plan and they're in the
middle of baby step two or three and
meaning they're getting out of debt or
they're saving money or whatever and
they're going along and they go well
what should I should I stop that and
pile up cash because the storms coming
should I stop that and Rachel there's
kind of two different situations on that
yeah for sure I mean I would always
encourage people if your income is still
coming in continue continue to stay
current on your debt pay them in
payments and keep going down attacking
the smallest to largest but if your
income completely stops then that kind
of puts you back in the category one
where it's okay pay minimum payments and
everything and just stockpile cash but
those are really the two main things
that I'm seeing that I'm hearing from
people yeah and so in other words if
like maybe he's a FedEx driver and she's
a teacher that incomes stable so the
only thing you're worrying about is
what's happening out here somewhere it's
not really happening in your house you
just keep doing your thing okay but but
if you got one of yous a real estate
agent and one of these got a hair salon
both of you are in trouble not yet but
if this thing if we don't get back to
work soon you're gonna have real
problems you probably ought to stop and
just pile up cash and get ready so how
stable and predictable is your current
income streams if they're stable and
predictable just keep plugging along but
if they're next to fall or you're afraid
they're gonna fall not just vague worry
but facts facts are your friends in a
crisis dr. Dolin he says and you just go
back to the facts what are the facts and
the facts are that you're okay if you
got two stable incomes keep plugging
along the facts are yeah there's
something wrong there's a problem we
need to stop and pile up cash and then
the third group that we're running into
are the people that are have done very
well they for many years have worked
our way out of debt they've invested in
their 401k they have an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses their
incomes are stable and predictable
they're still worried or concerned or
some of them are panicked even in that
situation because they the emotions got
the best of you in that situation and
and for those you're in a very unique
opportunity here if you can keep
perspective on how good you've got it in
this situation
you are in you're in the driver's seat I
tell everyone like we have always told
everyone never cash your mutual funds
out of your 401k unless it's to avoid a
bankruptcy or foreclosure so if you're
back in that group one before you get
foreclosed on if you have to use your
retirement fine but because I'm scared
no no no no no no hey you're right now
there's a there's a sale going on on
Wall Street these stocks are on sale
they're artificially low these companies
have not lost as much value as they
indicate with their stock prices so to
cash out right now would be absolutely
ludicrous you can remember this no one
gets hurt on a rollercoaster ride except
those that jump off in the middle of the
ride ride it baby I wrote it all the way
down in 2008 and all the way back out in
2008 before the crash 2007 the Dow had
topped out at 13,000 they went down to
6300 it went in half so when someone
tells you I lost all my money in the
stock market in 2008 no you didn't you
might have lost half of it but you
didn't lose it all it's mathematically
impossible to have lost it all unless
you were invested poorly in one single
stock and that company went broke you
did not lose all your money
you emotionally felt like you did but it
went from 13 to 6300 now for those of
you at home that don't follow the stock
market stuff from 6300 you know where it
was in January before it started the
coronavirus creep right it was at thirty
thousand five times as much money as
what she would have had so if you had a
million dollars when it was at the
bottom when everyone was freaking
out like they are right now you would
have had five million or you you would
have gone five four yeah got a million
dollars that would have gone to five
million dollars by now if the market
just returns if you put a thousand
dollars in today and if it just goes
back to where it was twelve months from
now you will have made forty percent on
your money now I don't know when it's
gonna go up I just think it's gonna go
up because I don't think America is over
I don't think that all the great
companies that you drive by is you're
driving down the highway that are traded
on the stock exchange are all suddenly
going to become worth zero because of
the coronavirus shutdown the corona
virus itself is not causing economic
problems the shutdown associated with
containing it is causing tremendous
economic problems so we need to keep
that in mind so far as of this broadcast
what we're facing is this for every case
of corona confirmed in the United States
approximately 100 people have already
lost their jobs due to the shutdown
that's the race yes and so we need to
keep these things in mind and watch how
this is going and be very very wise
about how long we're shut down
versus containment and those two things
are pulling at each other statistically
and both of them both of those curves
work on a geometric progression neither
one of them are 1 plus 1 equals 2 so
just be watching and be thinking and be
wise and calm down ride this out do not
cash up your stuff now if you're also in
that last category you're in good shape
I actually took a call on the radio this
week from a lady who was fearful and
they had two and a half million dollars
in their Roth IRA and mutual funds and
she said you know what we've we've lost
$600,000 I said did you cash your money
out and she said no and I said well you
lost evening that it just went down
if you cash it out you've lost it you've
locked in your losses we call it in the
investment business you haven't lost
anything
write it out write it out don't trap
your losses at the bottom and I think
that's a great point of our theme
tonight controlling the control boys we
can't control the show that we can't
control some of the things that are
going on right now but you can control
cashing out your investments so so
remember stay in it stay in it that is
one thing you can control you know those
of you that are in this group 3 focus on
that
and the other thing is some of you need
to refinance your mortgages there's
never been better mortgage interest
rates than in the last several weeks
these are incredible times and so if
you're sitting with a bad mortgage and
you're in good shape financially other
than that you probably like to look at
refinancing it right now right in the
middle of all this there's some
opportunities to buy some things right
now if you're sitting on some money
there's gonna be some opportunities to
buy some things at deep discounts and
believe me the people selling the things
would love to have you buy them they you
need to get rid of that stuff and so
there's some bargains gonna be had by
people who are in a position and your
blessing someone when you buy their
stuff real estate went way down in 2008
I bought a bunch of real estate and it
has been a one of the best investments
of my entire life I wish I could buy
real estate like that again except that
the only way I could do it is if the
whole freaking economy went down again
like that and I wouldn't wish that on us
just for me to get a deal but you're
looking you know you're in position do
that the other thing you're in a
position to do is to be generous if
you're sitting on two and a half million
dollars instead of fretting about losing
$300,000 in your 401k and you're 62
years old and by the way our household
income was $200,000 and Anthony I were
just laughing at her it was she was so
sweet she was terrified but all of that
was just fear had overcome her that
everything that worked for their whole
life was gonna be dissipated but I love
that point of being generous I think
that just counteracts completely the
fear right when you just step out and
you just think you know I'm gonna help
this neighbor this neighbor and this
family member here here in here I mean
like that it just changes your spirit
and on social media
I know you love social media today good
social media good yeah but looking even
like even an Instagram all these videos
are popping up of showing people and all
the creative ways that there are giving
and serving in their community so it
really is is it's kind of become a
united thing within our communities and
I think it's beautiful because think it
just completely counteracts the fear
yeah I think if you're going through a
drive-through right now some of your
quarantined and your in-house and some
of your areas and your going out just to
the restaurant doing drive-through
there's probably seventeen-year-old
that's standing there if you gave them
$100 you would blow their
mind triple quadruple your tips wherever
you go right now if you're sitting in a
good position
be generous something about generosity
takes your eyes off of you and the fear
just leaves and you start not being
there and so you start not having this
this idea that there's something about
fear that is selfish and when you're
selfless it adds hope and you start
taking your eyes off of your situation
and it might not be that you have a
bunch of money but you may be able to
just do something for someone you may be
able to be the person that delivers the
groceries that someone else bought to
someone who's an at-risk person who's
who's locked in right now and just do
things for other people we're seeing
that everywhere you're already doing
that there's lots of wonderful stories
what rachel was talking about but just
whoever's in the service business out
there still the ones that are still
there for goodness sakes they're they're
scared to death go in there and tip the
crud out of them and by the way you
probably do that the rest of your life
those people work hard they work really
hard so here's the thing if you're doing
really well
or if you're not don't cash out your
investments ride it out it's going to be
oh okay breathe do you really think that
Apple and McDonald's and Coca Cola and
Microsoft and Home Depot do I need name
companies like that for two days the
wonderful great American companies do
you really think they're all gonna be
worth zero at the end of this come on
now that's just the illogical it's just
not gonna happen and um if it does if
they're all worth zero we got bigger
problems than a virus our way of life is
gone and that's just not gonna happen
that didn't even happen in the stock
market crash of 29 some companies went
out but the entire economy did not
become more zero
so the way we project these fears and we
extrapolate them and when they grow into
this huge massive thing that's just not
even real it's impossible for it to be
real and I and I would say the last
thing kind of wrapping up the whole
money section though is one thing that
you can control obviously is the money
that is coming
and budgeting that's one of our huge
banners I feel like it Ramsey solutions
is helping you budget and that's just
being intentional with what every single
dollar is going we have a great
budgeting app every dollar I love it but
like it finding ways for you to be super
super intentional with every single
dollar and that's gonna be really
important during this time like even my
husband Winston and I we were talking
about the budget this month and we were
looking and I realized I just kind of
maternity leave just had a little boy
five months ago in like I felt we were a
little bit like loose with the budget we
still were on it and doing it but we
realized okay you know this this
motivated us to get even more stricter
and figure out where our ways that we
can even start to save and look and so
that is one thing you can control and be
intentional be intentional with your
money and do a budget knowing that
you've got enough because you wrote it
down gives you power
yeah it's controlling the controllables
and so you know that's how it works now
jobs jobs jobs jobs yeah I mean this
this Corona shutdown has affected people
people are afraid it's gonna affect them
and they're the other people are just
afraid it's gonna affect the overall
economy you're in that sector that's
what you do every day is help people
with their jobs and even with their
dreams and with their careers well
there's really two pandemics that we're
facing right now we've touched on this
obviously we have the medical pandemic
but we also have the pandemic of panic
and folks when when panic takes over you
lose all perspective Dave touched on
this earlier as he quoted our friend
world renowned economist art Laffer that
none of us can think clearly when we are
overcome by fear and panic because you
can't have perspective the only thing
you're seeing is that worst fear or
multiple fears if we look at today's
world right now we're talking about
multiple fears or coming at people all
day long and when that's what you're
focused on you can't have perspective
you know I get to talk to men and women
every day on the Ken Coleman show
helping them figure out what they were
created to do in their work and then
coming up with a plan to make that a
reality and I want to talk about
perspective for just a moment and and
then we'll get into the short term steps
right now for those of you who have lost
your job or you feel like that is coming
first let's look at the big picture
let's talk about perspective
yes this is an unprecedented time in
history there's no playbook for this it
just came on us very quickly and it is
affecting everyone but here's what you
can be certain of in an unprecedented
time of uncertainty that your purpose
your dreams haven't evaporated with this
crisis they just aren't all of a sudden
gone and you can't catch them
you can't pursue them that is a lie and
fear will tell you that you know I open
up every show by telling our listeners
that you were created to fill a unique
role that means you are needed and it
means you must do it and so I know there
are a lot of people that are watching
tonight that this crisis has either
stalled or it makes it makes it feel
like your dream has been threatened
maybe it feels like it's been taken away
maybe it's that business you just lost
or the business you were preparing to
launch maybe it was the career switch
maybe it was the entry point into the
very thing that you've been studying for
if you're a young student you're about
ready to graduate I can tell you with
absolute certainty tonight and I want
you to hear this and I want you to
believe it that no matter what you have
to do in this short term I can tell you
you will get back on track Davis said it
so well tonight you're going to be okay
we are going to be okay and I want you
to have the mindset right now that no
matter what delays have come your way
and all the uncertainty of when can I
get back on track how can I get back on
track I can tell you you will get back
on track so I want you to know that
there's a pause sometimes that life
throws at us and it's just a pause you
know I remember when DVR first came out
I'm a sports fan and it changed the game
because I could be watching the game and
if I wanted to go get some chips refill
the chips or a soda or whatever I could
press pause and I didn't miss anything
and I want you to have that sense I want
you to have that peace that confidence
that clarity that life is throwing a
pause at you but you're gonna get to get
back on track let's talk about more
perspective this economic situation
right now is an absolute
aberration this is not an economic
pattern I want to remind you with the
facts dave has quoted our good friend
John Delaney multiple times tonight and
John is absolutely right when we are
faced with fear we've got to focus on
the facts what are the facts end of
February we had a record jobs report for
a year and a half leading up to February
just weeks ago folks we were in a
historic job market in the United States
we were in a season a prolonged season
where we had more jobs available than
people who were unemployed
we had a job market where people were
being recruited and enticed to take the
very same job they had with one company
move over to a different company doing
the same job and make substantially more
money we had a job situation where
college students were coming out of
school and because they were new and
they could come right into the market
they were making more money sometimes
than folks that were more qualified or
had been in the sector for longer what
am I telling you that doesn't just
completely evaporate and disappear but
the reality is is that when people are
forced to go home for the medical
practices then they are contracting
their spending habits and it affects
companies far and wide and they've
listed several of them that are the most
hardest hit and so you're seeing crazy
unemployment numbers don't let that
cause you to panic even more that is to
be expected when essentially a
consumer-driven economy comes to a halt
now you need to understand this because
here's what's going to happen our
medical professionals are the best and
the brightest in the world they're going
to lead us and guide us and we will see
this virus flattened and eventually get
under control and when that happens we
will begin to see a very quick return to
normalcy and when that happens your
opportunities are going to be there
maybe even better and brighter than
before I'm not going to make you reveal
this to your friends and family if
you're gathered around watching this
together but here's what we know
Dave Rachael you've heard me say this
one
thousand times 70% of Americans were
unhappy in their work prior to this it's
not fun to get kicked out of the nest
but I can think through multiple times
in my life where I got kicked out of the
nest and it was the best thing that
happened to me and so I want you to have
that perspective as well and then third
let's talk about the short term we've
been talking about the long term but the
short term is what matters most
we opened up tonight we've said multiple
times through this conversation that our
theme is to help you see that you can
control certain things and so we want
you to control the controllables you
heard dave lay out the four walls you
heard Rachel talk about the budget to be
able to take care of the four walls
these are things that you can control
you will control them because you will
step up when you need to step up that's
what I believe about the human spirit
when we are squeezed when we are
challenged that's when the brightest
moments come when we choose to not be
defeated but we choose to get determined
and so let's look at the short term as
it relates to your job here's what we
know a lot of industries tourism hotels
cruise ships airlines hotels bars let's
call them non-essential priorities okay
think of Dave's four walls you think of
small businesses right now that aren't
in a high priority product or service
people are pulling back their money and
so it's it's gonna be painful for a
little bit but here's the deal you can
get work certain industries are
exploding we're seeing the delivery
system manufacturing warehousing yeah
don't get me started on toilet paper and
paper towel companies they're making it
as fast as they can make it we've seen
major big brands like CVS and Walgreens
obviously in the medical field they're
hiring like crazy Amazon so we have put
this information out at Randy's lucha's
we're gonna continue to bring it to you
but all you've got to do is say wait a
second I will deliver pizzas if I got to
deliver pizzas I'll do whatever it takes
in my area in my zip code to bring in
some money to take care of these four
walls I'm going to change my budget I'm
gonna I'm gonna do
something that maybe I've never done
before which is truly cut to the bone of
those most important things that I want
to bring you in for a second before I
wrap on this because I you started
talking about budgeting I mean people
can really get way down to the
nitty-gritty and they can begin to see
wait a second what I've got to cover
isn't as much as maybe I thought it was
the true essentials yeah absolutely I
mean once you get on a budget everyone
says I feel like I got a raise right
because you're just being that
intentional so yeah the budget is gonna
be your friend in this whole process if
you've lost your job but I also think
about you know if you are the person
that lost your job and you are the main
source of income it's your family and
you go home and you have a spouse and
kids they're like that's a scary thing
to say hey okay I am stuck like I lost
my job and and there's a real stress on
that I mean even just the kids being out
of school can we have young kids at oh
yes we're not home school teachers let's
just say it out loud me probably I can't
even spell Common Core but really I'm
like you know there's a there's a level
of stress within the family that's gonna
be caused by this but what you can
control is what he just talked about and
going and getting a new job and I think
you know it may take a little bit of
time for in a short term but doing that
I think is gonna is huge even from the
family landscape as well yeah and so
this comes down to what I think will be
a really big enemy for some of you right
now and that's pride we all suffer from
pride nobody's immune to it and what I
mean by this is you know I had a good
corporate job or ahead of whatever your
job was and all of a sudden you've got a
stock shelves at Walmart or your grocery
store and it feels like you've gone so
far backwards I'm speaking to you men
mostly here because we take such huge
identity as a provider but right now
this isn't a you problem there's no
shame in your game as one of my friends
says you've got to do what it takes to
provide those four walls don't have any
shame swallow your pride you do what you
have to do and I you know I love that
you brought up going home because that's
tough but I think our kids will learn
more from watching their parents step up
in a big moment of uncertainty and do
what needs to be done than they would
ever learn in any classroom
they're watching you don't be ashamed
you own it you show them what we're
doing as a family we're gonna sacrifice
we're gonna get through this and as Dave
said I believe six seven months from now
we're all gonna be going wow what a
weird time that was and those kids are
gonna see that and they're gonna
remember that
that's legacy type stuff I'll close my
thoughts Dave and Rachel on one of the
best analogies it's not even announced
it's actually true of nature and how two
different animals basically from the
same species handle the storms so cows
bless the cows when a storm is coming
across the plains or coming across the
pasture they see the storm coming and
they act like most humans do and maybe
how some of you some of us act when life
throws a storm at us they start to try
to outrun the storm but the storm
overtakes them Dave and then because the
storm is moving faster than they are
they spend more time in the storm
because they're trying to run away from
the storm but I don't know if it's their
cousin or what but the Buffalo these
crazy animals they're out on the plains
they see the storm they run into the
storm and as a result the storms coming
to the Buffalo and they run into it and
as a result they get through it quicker
I think you are facing a storm we are
facing a storm your business is facing
the storm our nation is facing a storm
our world is facing a storm I think what
we're going to share with you tonight
will help you take control of what you
can control and I know that you can
choose to run into the storm be like the
Buffalo run into that storm and you're
gonna get through it quicker don't run
away from it there's no reason to be
afraid of this we will overcome this
together and Ramsey solutions is going
to be there for you and with you the
entire time so what our takeaways for
you guys are tonight is
there's at least three things that you
can control we've talked about
controlling and controllables that gives
you a sense of power sense of hope to
push fear to the side panic to the side
hysteria to the side first thing is you
can control your attitude yes you really
can you're not a victim we didn't allow
Ramsey kids when they were growing up
Rachel or her brother or sister to say
he made me mad nope
you chose to be mad now maybe he was a
jerk and maybe it was an injustice and
maybe most people would be mad when that
happened but no one makes you afraid no
one makes you mad no one makes you happy
it's a decision you do control your
attitude and it's a matter of self
control self discipline and the people
that control their attitudes do control
a lot of the things that happen in your
life no one makes you unkind the
coronaviruses made me be mean to all my
neighbors on my facebook page in my
neighborhood no you were just being me
no one made you me and you need to stop
it you'd be kind calm and generous just
choose facts are your friends no one
controls your attitude absolutely yeah
number two is to control your money I
mean that's a big part of what we do
here at Ramsey solutions has helped you
with your money and man no matter what
category you're in we kind of walk
through the three different situations
but no matter where you are you can
control that part you know whether it's
the income coming in the spending that's
going out and so really really being
intentional with that and so things like
doing the budget
it's the banner I wave all the time but
it's true controlling that don't cash
out your investments deciding not to go
into debt in these situations I'm gonna
call the student loan people and tell
them I need a hardship deferral both of
us have lost our jobs and honestly I'm
happy that there's gonna be a government
stimulus but truthfully it's not enough
to fix your life if $1,000 fixes your
life
probably didn't have much of a life and
so it's it's a nice thing and I'm glad
for the politics and I'm glad for
whatever if it makes everybody feel good
up there but really what happens at your
house is more important than what
happens in the White House and it always
has been it always has been you get to
choose how to control the money that is
in your sphere and whether you're in a
crisis and the medium or whether you're
doing well you get to choose generosity
you get to choose to not take out your
investments at exactly the wrong time
you get to choose to not go into debt
because you panicked and freaked out
because you've been unemployed for 32
seconds before you went and ran up a
credit card the number of times I have
coached people on their finances and
they say oh I lost my job last year and
so I'm $45,000 in credit card debt and
when I talk them through it I figure out
that they lost their job for two months
and they were making $5,000 a month so
that means they needed $10,000 to
completely offset their loss of income
and yet they went $45,000 in debt and
used the job loss as an emotional
rationalization to do stupid stuff and
stupid
when we've been doing stupid stuff and
it goes into stress when stupid is
stress tested it comes up it shows you
as being stupid some people have been
doing some stupid stuff with money and
right now it's being revealed Warren
Buffett used to say that you know when
the tide goes out you can tell it was
skinny-dipping if the principles you're
operating your life on were false
principles and the only reason you were
getting away with it was a white-hot
economy now you know that they were
false and now you know the idea of being
out of debt being on a budget having
some savings is a really smart idea and
I'm not saying I told you so I've done
dumber than any of you looking I went
completely broke at my 20s and lost
everything because I did stupid stuff on
in a huge Tower of it and you know an
economy shift knocked the tower down and
I thought I was a victim I was a victim
of basing my life on wrong principles I
was the little pig with a straw house
and I changed my life some of you this
is gonna be the opportunity you change
your life
my grandpa Ramsay was one of my favorite
people on the planet when he was living
and I'll never forget in the 70s I was
in the backyard with him or pulling
neigh
out of boards on a deck we were taken
apart and every nail we pulled out we
had to straighten it out and put it in
the coffee can he kept used nails
because he was a young man just freshly
married with babies when the Great
Depression hit and it changed him
forever
he was frugal and careful with money
forever this might be yours someday your
grandson may be telling the story about
the time that there was a work stoppage
and people lost their jobs and you
permanently for the rest of your life
changed the way you handled money and
started basing it on gods and grandma's
common sense instead of going crazy out
here and extreme spending like most
people do this is an opportunity to
change that and so I'm not shaming you
if you messed up I'm here to help you if
you messed up I'm the king of haven't
messed up but this might be your wake-up
call this could be the best thing that
ever happened to some of you and the
third controllable is this you control
your opportunity that's right you know
the way that you think controls the way
that you act and when we've talked about
perspective tonight folks you've got to
understand that right now as Dave just
said you have some of you some very
urgent needs and so you are gonna have
to go get an opportunity you know when
we talk about proximity in the book the
proximity principle it's very simple
when you're around the right people and
in the right places opportunities
present themselves you've got to be ok
to say hey I need help I need some work
I'll do whatever it takes I got some
beautiful kids at home and I'm willing
to do whatever I'll work the midnight
shift I'll Drive I'll do whatever your
opportunity is right in front of you but
you're gonna have to go get it and
you're gonna have to be intentional and
again understanding the way that you
think is how you change the way that you
act if you think hey I can do this I
need to do this I must do this your
whole mindsets different and and I would
also be in a situation where you are
putting yourself in places for future
opportunity remember just because we've
got all this craziness and uncertainty
going on doesn't mean Dave and Rachel
that you can't put yourself not just in
the financial but in your job and you
can put yourself in a position that
when this thing slingshots back you're
ready for opportunity John Wooden may be
the greatest coach of all time the
legendary used to be at UCLA basketball
coach I am a fan he said this once and I
think it's beautifully said when
opportunity comes it's too late to
prepare and that those are wise words
and I think a challenge to us tonight
Dave's right you can control your
opportunities but you have to have the
mindset that I can make opportunities
happen Dave you're absolutely right not
just in our jobs but also as leaders in
our leading company if you're a pastor
right now you're leading the church a
bunch of you watching are friends of
mine they're doing that you're in
leading a small business at Ramsey we've
got about a thousand team members nine
hundred and forty some odd team members
just under a thousand if you're a leader
of an organization like that and people
are depending on you for the payroll to
come to them for them to feed their
families you're feeling the weight of
this as a leader times like this
leadership sucks some of your having to
make some really hard calls some really
tough decisions we're gonna be really
careful and make some decisions around
here just a couple days ago we started
pivoting a whole bunch of stuff around
here and some of you there's gonna be
some things you pivot that are like wow
that actually worked we might have
should have been doing that anyway some
of you are gonna try some things just to
hold on and create some revenue in your
business to be able to feed the families
and make the payroll that you're doing
and and that's okay it's okay do
whatever you need to do that that's the
right thing there pivot asks some ask
for things you've never asked for before
do things you've never done before we
sat in a group with our leadership team
on Monday morning I start saying what
can we help people with that are at home
stuck right now because I you know
obviously they're not going to come to
one of our events right how can we help
them how can we serve them and we start
think about all the things we have that
are digital that we can do we started
putting them up on a web page and going
okay cut that stuff to where there's no
profit let's just get it into these
households and help these people and we
did something we've never done before
a lot of you were on like a 14-day
lockdown so we said hey we're going to
take our nine week class Financial Peace
University which if you don't know
almost ten
and people have been through it now
we're gonna take that nine week class
it's all digital and you can watch all
the videos of Rachel and me and Anthony
only on Ken and Chris Hogan on there and
teaching you how to handle money
properly while you're at home and you
can binge watch it because we're gonna
make it available for you for a 14-day
free trial
we've never done that and so there's a
you take your business you change your
business around you organically think
through it right you go what can we do
different what can we do
will you take some of these audiobooks
and make them almost free what can we do
so that 14-day trial try it just go to
Dave Ramsey comm slash hope and sign up
for the 14-day trial for a financial
peace that way you can learn how to
handle money and it's an expansion on a
lot of stuff we've been talking about
tonight it's free free trial that's
what's called and so and it's got the
budgeting stuff in it the world's best
budgeting software is in there the every
dollar budgeting app that we built and
so on and so jump in there and get that
free thing and a bunch of other free
things we've got stuff you can do at
home with your kids we've got other
things a Rachel and I wrote a book
together called smart money smart kids
and then she taught a class on that
that's in that same free trial that you
can watch how to teach your kids how to
handle money so all kinds of stuff you
can do in there but businesses you can
you can pivot and do things just like
that and just find a way that you can be
generous to your customers while they're
hurting it like that or find a way that
you can serve them in a different way
and create revenue I don't care I'm not
afraid of your creating revenue I'm just
thinking these for a snapshot in time
try something different let this be the
shock that changes the status quo so the
thing we the three of us want you to
take away tonight is this you can
control only the controllables it'll
work like it all depends on you control
the controllables like it all depends on
you the things that are out of your
control aren't your job they're God's
and he's good at those he's good at this
and he'll take care of it it's gonna be
okay be kind
please quit shaming each other for being
angry with each other please fear is
contagious but hope is more contagious
thanks for joining us tonight
[Music]
[Music]